no you see sugar shane mosey one of the
greatest boxers of all time he's losing
his championship belt in a divorce
losing yeah it's like you're trying to
break a man why does she want those
right it's gonna break
they go with their shoes
no i love how when you get a divorce all
of a sudden it costs like 50 grand a
month to give a kid froot loops
[Laughter]
an epidemic of gold digging [__] in
this country
and it is just
not
being addressed
on any level what are you talking about
what do you mean what am i talking about
every guy out there is just getting
nobody's safe oh
arnold schwarzenegger's maid is still
called the maid
in the story
she knew his wife on a first-name basis
hooked up with this dude in their bed
and is still called the maid
why didn't she bang him
why
because of that 1987 flat top he's still
rocking right
you don't think it's because of that
kindergarten cop money he's got left
i'm not and listen
i'm not condoning
what the man did but you know there just
needs to be guys need to be educated
there's nothing out there
to help a guy handle becoming rich and
famous for that that platoon of [__]
that's gonna come over the hill
like like braveheart faces
yes
there's nothing out there
no it's like guys never learn how to
keep themselves in check
society does it for you yeah just women
aren't going to bang you because you
drive the forklift at home depot right
despite the fact that you want to bang
all of them they're not going to do it
so you didn't keep yourself in check the
forklift job did right
then all of a sudden you hit a lot the
lottery you know yeah
and then you can just give in to all of
that like i don't i'm so sick of all
these trolls coming on tv
judging these great men
these great men all these guys anytime
one of these guys gets caught for
screwing around these guys come waddling
out of their cubicles with their jowls
absolutely reprehensible behavior
like they have any idea what it's like
to be tempted at that level
you know yeah as you walk over to your
ford focus are you really beating these
women off of you
all those people who judge tiger woods
how many people here golf
what was the last time you walked off
the 18th hole and there was a busload of
scandinavian women waiting to hump your
brains out
and you're like sorry ladies you have to
understand that
[__] is like
it's the wheels on the car you
understand like if you have a beamer and
you have a benz and you go out and you
look at both of them 19
uh uh 2007 benz 2007 beamer you look at
them both and and if the salesman comes
up and goes hey how are you oh listen i
have a wonderful car here you go well
what's the what's some of the features
of the car why should i buy it because
it has wheels
what [__]
that's what a [__] is any woman
her initial thing she doesn't have any
guidance to think differently is that
she has to get something out of her
[__] this is why going back to the
other caller why they force you to marry
them because it's like
it's like um dracula trying to trying to
eat dinner with you real fast before 5am
comes you understand that's a [__]
that's a [__]
she want to get married to she want to
get married before she turns before
you got to understand that that's what i
wanna get married it's it's get i gotta
get this [__] so that i have an
excuse not to have to be bigger than my
vagina if you make her stretch out that
that that courtship
she's gonna have to force herself to be
bigger than her vagina and some women
don't know how to do that oh i have an
announcement to read i almost forgot i
was supposed to i was told to
make this announcement uh table ten
wherever you are table ten we're sorry
your waitress hasn't been there in a
while
larry king just married her so
so
are you here with your wife bro
you're not married as your girlfriend oh
but you were married before
gosh who got you and do you think you'll
get married to her
[Applause]
i'm sorry sweetheart
i'm sorry you found out today
yeah they already know but they don't
every girl goes into the relationship
thinking oh yeah you don't want to get
married you're not serious but then they
grind you away
oh the woman of course
what do we get out of it
yeah it's 100 for the woman like think
about it you get married to us you get
half our [__]
right
we get married to you we get half your
[__] here's the difference
no girl is dumb enough to marry a dude
that got less [__] than her
[Applause]
only we're stupid enough to marry these
broke [__] bro
that's how great [__] feels you're
inside's a [__] like [__] he's half my
[__] brother
what am i gonna do with all this [__] i
got all this [__] i'm gonna keep it to
myself this is crazy
this guy went through it once he's like
i'm not getting burned again
guaranteed by next year they're married
guaranteed
100 guarantee
i promise you but this is how it starts
it's how it starts doc
we do the same thing with anal it's the
same [__] right slowly
you slowly grind away and wear them down
right
right we marry them then finally we get
in the ass gotcha [__]
you know i gotcha there's no prenup for
anala
what if he what if he changed his mind
sweetheart what if he was like i would
really love to get married
you never wanted to get married
really
your mom was married three times
no that's some fire [__] right there
i'm not gonna lie
she probably crazy like your mom's
probably out of her mind crazy but she
got fired [__] she got three different
dudes
three different dudes to get down on one
knee
before you marry her you got to try out
some of that mom [__] bro
[Applause]
i guess the apple doesn't fall far from
the tree there is no sex man i had no
idea that marriage just means no sex no
none [__] none
i have friends that are thinking of
getting married and they say funny [__]
like hey you know i don't know if i
could do it because i don't know if i
could have sex with one woman for the
rest of my life
like don't worry about that [__]
you're gonna have sex with zero women
for the rest of your life that's a lot
less than one
one woman who the [__] you think you are
where'd you get that fantasy
i'd love to have sex with one woman for
the rest of my life any one woman big
fat dead lady with a beard i'd [__] her
every day
i'd be proud to have her
that's not usually my problem these days
my problem is very simple it's trying to
find a place in my house where i can
masturbate without somebody bothering me
and that's
really difficult
there's nowhere to go anymore she's got
her mother staying with us too in the
guest room and i'm on the streets now i
got nowhere to go
like now i know when i see a guy in the
west side highway jerking off and
playing daylight that's not a homeless
guy that's a married man right there
[Applause]
he's got nowhere to go
[__] it [__] you go ahead and look man i
got no no what else am i gonna do
it's not fair man i'm 37 and i own my
home i should be able to just stand in
the living room how are you doing honey
huh good morning
but i can't i gotta hide i'm down in the
cellar by the boiler like a troll down
there
just [__] miserable [__]
that's what it's like masturbation
doesn't bring much joy to guys women
seem to like masturbating they put
flower petals on the pillow they're like
ah me or whatever you know
[Applause]
the guys are looking at [__] never
[__]
[Music]
god damn it
sometimes you find ecstasy but it's
followed by the deepest self-hate and
depression you've ever felt it's an
amazing drop from way up here to this
like oh yeah what the [__] is wrong with
me god damn it
i gotta get to work i don't have time
for this [__] right now
[Applause]
but then you get married now you gotta
hide and you have to you have to hide
because when your wife catches you
masturbating that that's sad for the
whole family that's not
not a good moment in a marriage
she comes in the cellar oh my god
and then she always wants to know [__]
about it
she always asks me stuff my wife's like
well do you think about me when you're
doing that
what are you [__] high why would i do
that
what i can think about anybody that's
magical
why the [__] would i i'm married to you
what do women really think their
husbands are going oh my wife oh yeah
that's [__] hot
oh yeah
picking her up at the airport and
getting yelled at oh that's [__] hot
yeah
put it in the hamper not on top you
idiot oh i love when she talks like that
yeah
but uh you know whatever
we're a family we have a kid that
changes everything
that's the whole thing the kid is
everything marriage is nothing without a
kid marriage is dating it doesn't mean
[__] and you don't realize it till you
have a kid here's what happens when you
get married you go holy [__] i can't
leave now i mean i wasn't thinking of
leaving but now i really can't leave
then you have a kid you go holy [__] i
could have left